alors je le disais on va consacrer
largement ce club à la loi immigration
puisque aujourd'hui est attendue la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
ce texte un texte dont on a beaucoup
parlé depuis des mois l'une des mesures
de durcissement pour être retoqué par
les sages du Conseil constitutionnel
cette mesure elle a été ajoutée par les
républicains elle prévoit de supprimer
plusieurs aides sociales pour les
étrangers pendant une certaine période
notre reporter est allé à la rencontre
d'un afgan qui explique la nécessité
pour s'intégrer de ces aides sociales
Flora sauvage
Aref a quitté l'Afghanistan en 2016
arrivé en France après un long périple
il a bénéficié de prestations sociales
une prime d'activité et une aide au
logement qui lui a permis de se loger
dans la capitale c'était une aide très
importante parce que comme on est seul
ici pas de famille pas de garant rien du
tout imaginez que moi j'avais un salaire
de 1200 € 1 300 € avec 2 300 400 € de
aide de logement et prime activité ça
faisait moitié plus moitié de mon
salaire prestation d'accueil du jeune
enfant àocation familiale ou aide au
logement avec la loi imigration ces
prestations sociales pourraient être
conditionné pour les étrangers en
situation régulière à une durée de
présence en France un minimum de 5 ans
sur le territoire sera nécessaire pour
les étrangers qui ne travaillent pas et
de 30 mois pour ceux qui ont un emploi
cette disposition provoque la fronde des
départements de gauche ce texte il va
précariser encore un peu plus des
familles déjà fragile vulnérable et il
va instaurer effectivement une
discrimination entre des familles qui
sont pourtant dans les mêmes situations
économiques et sociales et donc avec
l'ensemble des départements de gauche et
bien nous avons décidé de mettre en
place une prestation volontariste extra
extralégale qui permettrait de compenser
la perte de la loocation pour
l'autonomie des personnes âgées dans une
note qui analyse l'impact de la loi
immigration le collectif nos services
public s'alarme chiffre à l'appui de la
popérisation accrue des personnes
étrangères on peut citer par exemple le
cas de deux femmes aide soignantes qui
ont toutes les deux un enfant qu'elles
élèvent seul pour l'une le fait d'avoir
son mitant d'êt soignante mitemp
contraint et les prestations sociales va
lui permettre de gagner environ 1600 €
par mois pour l'autre qui avec la loi
perdrait l'ensemble de ses allocations
sociales et familiales basculerait sous
le seuil de grande pauvreté c'est-à-dire
gagnerait environ 650 € par mois soit un
écart de près de 1000 € pour la seule
différence de nationalité l'article 19
de la loi asile immigration pourrait
toutefois être censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel ce
jeudi Frédéric dab est-ce que les
Français sont pour ce durcissement des
aides sociales pour les étrangers alors
clairement oui alors déjà il faut le
dire ce rendez-vous du Conseil
constitutionnel est très peu peu attendu
par les Français ils ne l'ont pas en
tête pour eux la loi a été votée on se
souvient des péripéties du mois de
décembre on va pas y revenir et sur
cette loi je suis frappé de voir le
décalage entre la scène parlementaire où
on a vu un clivage gauche-droite
extrêmement fort on a vu une majorité
présidentielle se fracturer hein 60 58
ou 60 de mémoire députés qui n'ont pas
voté de la loi ou qui se sont abstenus
et c'est comme ça on le voit dans les
enquêesop une opinion publique assez
assez consensuelle avec je dirais un
effondrement de clivage gauche- droite
qui par le passé était très prégnant sur
la question migratoire deux petits
exemples le fait d'expulser des
deslinquant étrangers à l'issu de leur
peine est soutenu par 3/4 des
sympathisants de gauche en rupture avec
l'imaginaire de la gauche sur
l'immigration tel qu'on l'entend mais
qui n'existe plus et de la même manière
on avait une nette majorité de
sympathisants de droite qui était
favorable tenez-vous bien la
régularisation céit un des aspects de la
loi de sans papiier dans des métiers en
tension donc donc l'opinion publique est
beaucoup plus consensuelle que par le
passé elle voulait avant tout une loi
elle voulait avant tout de l'action si
cette loi n'avait pas été votée ça
aurait été une catastrophe pour
l'exécutif de l'époque c'est-à-dire
madame borne et et et le couple borne
Macron puisque la grille de lecture en
terme de il se passe rien en terme
d'inaction commençait à structurer
beaucoup les choses à être une grille de
perception de la part des Français
l'arrivée de Gabriel Atal et son
mouvement la dynamique qu' l'imprime a
complètement changer les choses mais de
ce point de vue-là l'opinion publique a
été plutôt en décalage avec ce qui s'est
passé avec la scène parlementaire et
pour répondre à votre question oui elle
est sur une logique de durcissement des
aides sociales parce que il y a un
sentiment d'équité et vu la souffrance
que connaî beaucoup de Français donc un
décalage entre l'opinion et la classe
politique sur cette question de
l'immigration est-ce que les Français
sont pour l'idée de la préférence
nationale les opposants de gauche au
texte estiment que cette loi immigration
elle va renforcer la préférence
nationale alors euh préférence nationale
on va le dire c'est un c'est un mot que
j'appellerai un mot vol de mort pour
citer le le méchant de l'époque d'Harry
Potter c'est-à-dire que dès dès qu'on se
prononce ce mot voilà c'est vraiment en
fait l'épouvantail et ça crispe beaucoup
mais lorsque je teste dans une enquête
même auprès des jeunes le fait de
réserver les emplois en cas de période
de fort chômage à des Français il y a
2/3 de la jeunesse qui est favorable il
y a 3/4 des Français mais le terme
préférence nationale est les mots ont un
sens chis un tel historique une telle
réminiscence de l'époque de Jean-Marie
leupen c'était hein c'était vraiment la
dans l'ofre programmatique du lepénisme
des années 80 90 c'était vraiment le le
cœur du programme et l'élément qui
distinguait très fortement le Front
national de ce que Jean-Marie Le Pen
appelait la bande des quat donc parler
préférence nationale dans une question
d'enquête brouill choses mais quand on
pose le principe qui existe dans toute
une série de choses l'accès à des postes
dans dans l'administration c'est seul
les Français peuvent candidater on a une
opinion publique qui est plutôt
largement favorable et là aussi
lesclivages politiques se sont fortement
atténués Paul Cassia en tant que
spécialiste du droit en tant que
constitutionnaliste est-ce que vous
diriez que cette loi immigration instore
renforce la notion de préférence
nationale alors les mots préférence
nationales ne sont pas employés dans la
loi mais la chose est là puisquen effet
il y a une un effet de ciseau de plus en
plus fort qui est créé par cette loi
entre les droits des nationaux des
Français et les droits des étrangers
euh et cet effet de ciseau il n'est pas
sans poser question que le Conseil
constitionnel aura à tranché peut-être
pas cette fois-ci on va y revenir mais
en tout cas à d'autres occasions euh
poser question regarde du principe
d'égalité de traitement parce que quand
même on a un texte fondamental dans
notre Constitution c'est la Déclaration
de
1789 qui prévoit c'est son article 1er
que les hommes demeurent libre et égaux
en droit quelle que soit leur
nationalité donc est-ce que cette
distorsion des droits entre ceux des
nationaux et ceux des étrangers est
conforme à l'égalité et à la fraternité
c'est au Conseil constitutionnel d'en
décider et bien justement on va voir
quelle mesure Mathias pourrait être
retoqué dans cette loi imigration par
les sages du Conseil constitutionnel
c'est ça les sages doivent se prononcer
sur quatre cisine déposé fin décembre
contre le texte suite à son adoption au
Parlement alors par cisine on entend un
processus de contrôle de la conformité
d'un texte avec la Constitution pendant
ce processus la promulgation du texte
est suspendue comme je vous le disais
Alexandre il y en a quatre à ce jour une
déposée par la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale yelbron Pivet une par une
soixantaine de députés de gauche une
autre par une soixantaine de sénateurs
de gauche et enfin une dernière une
saisine blanche signé par signée par
Emmanuel Macron en personne dans
laquelle il demande au Conseil de rendre
un avis sur le texte sans énoncer
toutefois le moindre grief alors quelle
mesure pourrait être retoqué alors les
deux saisines les plus hosy au texte
vous vous en doutez sont celles des
parlementaires de gauche elle demande
dans les grandes lignes au sages
d'argumenter sur chacun des articles sur
lesquels plane l'ombre de
l'inconstitutionnalité et donc de la
censure on retrouve par exemple les
mesures qui ont trait à l'acquisition de
la nationalité française le texte
conditionne notamment l'acquisition de
celle-ci à un certain niveau de langue
met fin à l'automaticité du droit du sol
pour les enfants d'étranger né en France
ou encore la déchéance de nationalité
après une condamnation pour homicide
volontaire commis sur toute personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique et
une attention particulière sera
également portée à des mesures qui sont
chères à la droite sénatoriale ou on l'
évoqué le conditionnement de certaines
prestations sociales le durcissement du
regroupement familial la caution pour
les étudiants étrangers il en avait été
question le placement en rétention de
certains demandeurs d'asile ou encore le
débat annuel au Parlement afin de fixer
des quotas migratoires PL pluriannuels
au total sur les 86 articles que
comporte la loi 44 sont visés par des
grifs et essentiellement les cavaliers
fiscaux entendaient sans lien avec
l'objet de la loi si certains imaginent
déjà ou espèrent plutôt une censure
totale du texte beaucoup de juristes
s'accordentàdire que le Conseil
constitutionnel devrait simplement
alléger le texte des calavaliers fiscaux
et donc revenir à une version un peu
plus proche de celle proposée au départ
par Gérald armanin merci beaucoup
Mathias Paul casscia quelle mesure de
cette loi immigration êtes-vous le plus
certain qu'elles vont être retoqué alors
d'abord il y a effectivement quatre
saisies
certaines sont vides celles du président
de la République ce qu'on appelle une
saisine blanche d'autres sont plus
complètes mais peu importe le Conseil
constitionnel est saisi de tout le texte
et il va examiner les 86 articles
Alexandre a rappelé ce chiffre
alors
pardon alors il y a des dispositions qui
sont inconstitutionnelles c'est reconnu
par tout le monde lesqu par le ministre
de l'intérieur par le président de la
commission des lois par le Président de
la République lui-même les lesqueles et
ben très vraisemblablement toutes celles
qui ont beaucoup de celles qui ont été
ajouté par le Sénat en commission mixte
paritaire pour la raison que vient
d'évoquer Mathias c'est que ces
dispositions sont ce qu'on appelle des
cavaliers législatifs c'est-à-dire que
ce sont des dispositions qui n'ont pas
de rapport direct ou indirect avec
l'objet initial de la loi ça veut pas
dire qu'elles sont inconstitutionnelles
ça veut dire qu'elles sont sans sans
objet par rapport au texte de la loi et
notamment parmi ces disp i il y a toutes
celles qui sont relatives à la
protection sociale que vous venez
d'évoquer qui risque d'être balayé en en
une petite ligne en disant qu'elles sont
hors sujet donc ça veut dire que ces
mesures là elles peuvent être balayées
et ensuite réintroduites dans dans une
autre loisent absolument voilà et on
estime que sur les 86 articles il y a au
moins une quarantaine si ce n'est
davantage de mesures qui sont hors sujet
par rapport au texte de la loi et à
celela s'ajoute des dispositions qui
sont vides dans leur contenu je peux
vous en donner don quelques exemples ça
s'appelle des neutrons législatifs
allez-y ouais par exemple le Sénat a
indiqué a ajouté ceci euh si les parents
l'étranger s'engage à assurer à son
enfant une éducation respectueuse des
principes et des valeur de la République
le l'étranger s'engage à assurer à son
enfant une éducation respectueuse ça
c'est pas un texte normatif ça n'a pas à
figurer dans une loi c'est une pétition
de principe et le Conseil constitionnel
ne censure ce genre de disposition ça
s'appelle t neutron législatifs il y en
a d'autres donc ça aussi ça sera balayé
donc alors il y a les mesures hors sujet
il y a les mesures qui ne relèvent pas
la loi et est-ce qu'il y a des mesures
qui sont vraiment inconstitutionnelles
selon vous et qui sont hors de l'État de
droit par ex
absolument en particulier et je sais que
nous sommes de nombreuses universitaires
à penser la même chose toutes les
dispositions qui qui sont relatives aux
étudiants étrangers qui viennent en
France qui sont catastrophiques pour
notre image à l'international il a une
ex une
caution les étuds étrangers et en
particulier le Sénat a introduit une
disposition qui est tout à fait
contreproductive et tout à fait négative
pour l'image de la France qui oblige les
universités à majorer les droits
d'inscription de tous les étudiants
étrangers y compris les Australiens y
compris les Américains y compris les les
étudiants qui viennent d'Amérique du Sud
ça c'est illégal parce que la
Constitution prévoit que l'inscription à
l'université est gratuite voilà donc il
y a d'autres dispositions du du même
Akabi en fait le problème c'est qu'il
n'y a pas eu de filtre toutes ces
dispositions ont été ajoutées par le
Sénat en CMP commission mixte paritaire
réunion députés et sénateur à l'arrache
sans avis préalable du Conseil d'État
sans étude d'impact et dans le H Clos de
la commission mixte paritaire Frédéric
dabiss si cette loi immigration était
balayée pour reprendre les mots de Paul
Cassia par les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que ça pourrait
être mal perçu par les Français oui
clairement oui parce que je le répète la
beaucoup de Français on peut faire un
micro trottoire voir une enquête
d'opinion n'ont pas en tête ce processus
du Conseil constitutionnel et pour eux
c'est une dimension un peu performative
du politique il y a une loi elle a été
votée on s'en souvient comment et pour
les Français elle s'applique presque
presque déjà c'est le fameux quand dire
c'est faire de la part des politiques et
V une loi c'est déjà elle existe elle
est elle est déjà euh fa appliquer les
beaucoup de Français n'ont pas en tête
je crois j'ai plus la le chiffre en tête
qu'énnormément de lois on attend des
décr des décrets pardon d'application et
elle nentre en vigueur que plusieurs
mois voir plusieurs années après son
vote donc en terme d'attente
d'efficacité des Français vis-à-vis du
politique ça pourrait être dévastateur
d'autant plus que bien sûr je pense que
il y a toute une série de dispositifs de
la loi qui n'ont pas été testés dans les
enquêtes d'opinion mais Cell que
Monsieur Cassia vient de rappeler sur
les étudiants oui on trouvera pas de
majorité de Français favorable à un
durcissement d'entré des étudiants parce
qu'il y a cette dimension cet imaginaire
sur l'image de la France on se souvient
à la fin du quincan de Nicolas Sarkozi
déjà des dispositions sur les étudiants
étrangers qui avaient été très mal perçu
par les français de gauche et droite
mais en tout cas si cette loi est je
dirais pasit balayée mais très fortement
remagnée il y aura sans doute une
déception sur le mode tout ça pour ça et
sur le mode en fait on nous a dit que
une loi est rentré en vigueur ce n'est
absolument pas le cas donc c'est
possiblement un risque d'opinion donc
c'està-dire queon a l'impression
qu'Emmanuel Macron espère que certaines
mesures vont être censuré par les sages
C blanche dont vous avez parlé ouais
mais cette censure ça pourrait avoir un
effet contreproductif sur l'image du
gouvernement dans sa politique
migratoire il il y aurait une déception
oui il y aura une déception Gabriel sera
sans doute épargné puisqu'il n'était pas
aux affaires à ce moment-là mais c'est
bien sûr un risque un risque d'opinion
dans la dans la mesure où ce qui est
très fr frappant dans les enquêtes
d'opinion c'est l'espoir de changement
que porte Gabriel Atal et le fait qu'on
lui associe très fortement le mouvement
l'action une forme de dynamique
c'est-à-dire une sorte par homotéie de
faire à Matignon ce qu'il a réussi à
faire en 6 mois au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale donc une censure
pourra être perçue comme de l'inaction
Paul Cassia je le disais on a
l'impression que le Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron en fait
espère cette censure des sages du
Conseil constitutionnel finalement qu'il
il se repose sur eux pour que ces
mesures qui ont été imposées par la
droite et bien soi balayé ça pose quand
même un problème institutionnel un
énorme problème cette loi sur
l'immigration est l'exemple de ce qu'il
ne faut pas faire en matière
constitutionnelle on ne renvoit pas
enfin on on ne transmet pas au Conseil
constitutionnel un texte qui est
manifestement inconstitutionnel voté par
le Parlement les inconstitutionnalités
doivent être réglé au niveau d'abord du
Parlement et quand le texte est clair du
point de vue constitutionnel euh au
Parlement ensuite il peut aller au
Conseil constitutionnel et il y a je
voudrais simplement citer sur ce point
très rapidement bien sûr bien sûr une
circulaire qui avait été adoptée par
Michel Rocard alors Premier ministre le
27 mai 1988 il avait adressé à tous ses
ministres et il y avait un point qui
s'appelle qui s'appelait respect de
l'État de droit et il écrivait ceci à
tous ses ministres il convient de tout
faire pour éliminer les risques
d'inconstitutionnalité susceptible
d'entacher les projets de lois et les
amendements je considère en effet comme
l'honneur du gouvernement de ne porter
aucune atteinte fut-elle mineure et sans
sanction à l'État de droit et là on fait
le contraire on vote un texte qui est
manifestement inconstitutionnel et on
renvoie la balle au Conseil
constitutionnel et bien justement vous
citiez Michel recard et bien on va
écouter Laurent fabus le président du
Conseil constitutionnel qui a fait une
sorte de recadrage d'Emmanuel Macron sur
le rôle du Conseil constitutionnel qui
ne serait pas et bien interprété dans
cette loi immigration on va écouter
Laurent fabus puisqu'il était sur Public
Sénat le 11 janvier dernier il a une
tâche bien précise qui est de vérifier
si les lois qui sont votées par les
parlementaires sont conformes ou pas à
la constitution la Constitution c'est la
loi des lois bon il n'a pas d'autres
rôle c'est ça et donc il ne se situe pas
sur le terrain proprement politique il
se situe sur le terrain de la loi il
regarde objectivement impartialement for
la Constitution Paul Cassen en fait
Emmanuel Macron considère le Conseil
constitutionnel comme une une chambre
d'appel de la loi pour des raisons
politiques en l'occurrence oui et c'est
très mauvais pour l'image du Conseil
constitutionnel parce que rien de bon ne
pourra en sortir ce n'est pas le rôle du
Conseil constitutionnel que de filtrer
ainsi les dispositions qui ont été
massivement adoptées par par le
Parlement et ce que vient de rappeler le
Président fabus c'est exact et tout le
monde le sait depuis 1985 c'est la
jurisprudence constante qui veut que la
loi n'exprime la volonté générale que
dans le respect de la Constitution c'est
la jurisprudence constante du Conseil
constitionnel depuis 1985 alors ce débat
il s'inscrit dans un bras de faire
politique entre Emmanuel Macron et les
républicains et d'ailleurs on va écouter
Bruno rotao le président du groupe LR au
Sénat qui estime lui aussi qu'Emmanuel
Macron et bien est en train de dévoyer
le rôle du Conseil constitutionnel il y
a un dévoiement des institutions de la
République quand le président de
République qui encourage sa majorité
très largement à voter le texte au Sénat
ils l'ont voté avec nous en première
lecture vous vous souvenez et puis
ensuite à l'Assemblée nationale dit
aussitôt après ah je saisis le Conseil
constitutionnel comme si le Conseil
constitutionnel est être une sorte
d'instance d'appel du Parlement Frédéric
dab en fait on est dans un règlement de
compte politique entre l'lr et la
majorité présidentielle sur cette
question je pe permett dire qu'il
n'intéresse absolument pas les Français
les les ce type de jout politique
icienne est complètement en déconnexion
en décalage avec les attentes qui se
cristallisent sur la santé l'éducation
le pouvoir d'achat et la sécurité c'est
très très intéressant ce que vous dites
sur et ce qui a été dit sur ce
dévoiement enfin ce Conseil
constitutionnel qui n'est plus vraiment
dans son rôle tel que le saisi le
président de la République et le fait de
lire un texte de Michel Rocard est
encore plus notable Michel rokard
également n'avait pas de majorité
absolue on peut dire comme ça que ce qui
vient ce qui ce qui se passe sous nos
yeux est lié à une sorte de péché
original cette originelle cette
semi-victoire semi-défate de la de la
majorité présidentielle aux élections
législatives de juin 2022 le fait de pas
avoir de majorité absolue et donc tout
ce qui en a découlé mais Michel Rocard
pour autant sans majorité absolue
utilisant 28 fois le 493 n'a jamais été
dans ce rou là en tout cas sur le bras
de fer LR majorité ça ne concerne pas
les français puisque le le fait majeur
je dirais sur la question migratoire de
ces dernières années c'est le
rapprochement des points de vue très
spectaculaires par exemple sur la
déchéance de nationalité entre
sympathisant de gauche sympathisant de
droite et un durcissement de l'opinion
qui n'empêche pas une opinion
relativement équilibrée pour citer
encore Michel Rocard sa fameuse phrase
la France ne peut pas accueillir toute
la misère du monde mais elle doit en
prendre sa part je je je sais pas
exactement mot mais c'était un peu cette
idée làà alors que l'opinion publique se
durcit sur la question migratoire avec
cette idée d'insécurité culturelle vécu
dans par des Français dans leur vie
quotidienne pour autant dans toutes les
enquêtes je pense à celle fait par
l'phop pour le JDD la Fondation jean-
jores on trouve une majorité de français
de gauche et même de droite qui
considèrent que c'est le devoir de la
France d'accueillir des réfugiés des
étrangers fillant à la guerre ou la
misère Paul casscia ce durcissement de
la loi immigration qui a été imposé par
les républicains au euh macroniste à
Emmanuel Macron à la majorité
présidentielle finalement il résulte
d'une situation institutionnelle he
cette majorité relative c'est blocage à
l'Assemblée nationale oui oui mais il y
a une motion de rejet qui a été votée à
l'Assemblée nationale en première
instance peut-être qu'il aurait fallu
s'arrêter là c'était possible aussi
simplement le président de la République
a voulu aller jusqu'au bout du processus
et ce faisant il s'est mis dans les
mains du Sénat et ce faisant ont été
adopté des dispositions qui n'ont pas
été filtrées
et ça a conduit le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald harmanin à dire en
séance publique au Sénat le 19 décembre
2023 je le cite certaines dispositions
de ce texte citations sont manifestement
et clairement contraire à la
Constitution et pourtant il a appelé à
ce qu'elle soit votée je ne peux que
rejoindre ce que vient de dire le
Président rotao il y a un instant c'est
tout à fait contraire à la logique du
respect de l'État de droit que de voter
des lois qui sont manifestement
contraires à la Constitution alors il y
a ce fait là vous évoquez également la
motion de rejet qui qui avait été voté
par l'Assemblée nationale en décembre
contre cette loi immigration on a
l'impression que pour des raisons
politiques actuellement et bien les
différentes formations politiques
utilise toutes les ficelles tous les
rouages de nos institutions de nos
règles juridiques pour et bien gagner ce
bras de fer oui c'est parfaitement
normal puisque Frédéric Diabi vient de
le rappeler nous sommes dans une
configuration particulière où la
majorité présidentielle est relative et
par conséquent il faut au coup par coup
trouver des majorités pour chaque texte
de façon à ce que ceci passe aboutir
soit des compromis soit utiliser des
dispositions constitutionnelles inédites
comme ça a été fait pour la loi sur les
retraites on va on va conclure ce débat
peut-être en évoquant la suite après
cette loi immigration après cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel et
bien on continuera à parler
d'immigration puisque Gabriel hatal a
dit qu'il tiendrait la promesse
d'éliisabeth borne faite au républicains
et bien de faire une réforme de l'aide
médicale d'État qui permet de soigner
les étrangers en situation irrégulière
Frédéric dab c'est un débat sur cette
aide médicale d'État qui peut aussi
concerner les les Français oui alors
c'est un sujet qu' est qu' ne cite
quasiment jamais spontanément quand on
parle d'immigration il parle plutôt de
de perte d'autorité de perte de contrôle
de l'État sur la maîtrise de ces
frontières c'est vraiment l'idée d'une
perte d'autorité de l'État plus que plus
que des dispositifs particuliers comme
laame mais une enquête siope fait au
mois de septembre mon que tr/4 des
França 7 est favorable à une réforme de
laame parce qu'il y a ce sentiment vrai
ou pas qu'il n'y a qu' a plus qu'il n'y
a pas de réciprocité entre ou pas de
d'égalité entre des Français en
situation financière compliquée et des
étranger aidés dans le cadre de l'Ame ça
aussi he c'est un sujet de
cristallisation très forte dans la scène
politique entre gauche et droite entre
RN reconquête d'un côté et l'anupes mais
qu' que l'on ne retrouve pas ce débat
cette fracturation dans l'opinion
publique c'est une sorte de symbole il y
a vraiment une image assez négative de
laame dans dans l'opinion alors que par
exemple un rapport commandé par le
gouvernement et bien mes connaissances
mais estime que c'est c'est quand même
utile pour la santé publique le débat
s'il y a un débat il sera vu par les
Français et peut-être que il y a a
aucune raison que les Français ne qu'il
ait pas une évolution d' en publ mais
puisqu'on est sur une une opinion
publique qui considère à 2 tiers que
l'immigration plus qu'elle ne rapporte
c'est leur c'est la perception des
français laame s'inscrit dans cette idée
que l'immigration finalement coûte cher
merci pour toutes ces explications
messieurs vous restez avec nous on va
regarder ce qu'il y a dans la presse
[Musique]
régionale Mathias à la une des
quotidiens régionaux sans surprise il y
a la crise agricole oui et le phénomène
prend de l'ampleur j'ai dû trier ce
matin Alexandre tant le nombre de titres
de presse régionaux traitant le sujet
est important pelmel donc on a le
populaire du centre et ses racines du
ralbol le vent de colère des
agriculteurs pour pressocéan la montagne
qui constate que la colère s'étend
sud-ouest ouvre les guillemets et cite
un agriculteur on est en train de crever
le Courrier Picard annonce que les
tracteurs sont arrivés à Amien et enfin
l'ardénis prophétise un mouvement parti
pour durer alors il y a aussi un autre
sujet dans la presse régionale ce matin
mais on reste encore dans la réalité oui
le républicain Laurin traite dans ses
pages d'un sujet bien connu dans les
campagnes les querelles de voisins ces
dernières années on a souvent entendu
parler d'histoire ubuesque de citadin
néorurau qui porte plainte contre un coq
qui chante trop tôt ou les odeurs de
l'épandage une proposition de loi vise à
limiter les recours excessifs dans les
conflits de voisinage à la campagne et
puis Mathias forcément la loi
immigration fait aussi la lune oui la
Marseillaise donne la parole ce jeudi à
des juristes fait la part belle au
témoignage et à l'analyse avant l'heure
de vérité c'est le titre concernant le
sort de la loi immigration l' assez
évoqué la loi immigration qui est donc
entre les mains du Conseil
constitutionnel et puis il y en a
d'autres qui sont fixés sur leur sort
oui c'est le groupe Casino qui a annoncé
ce mercredi la reprise de l'essentiel de
ces super et hyper marché par auchamp et
Intermarché une opération valorisée à
plus d'un milliard d'euros et qui
permettrait de sauvegarder plus de 12000
emplois une nouvelle traité localement
par plusieurs journaux comme la
République des Pyrénées libération
champagne ou lest éclair car oui même si
on parle de plus d'un milliard d'euros
cela reste une information qui qui qui
relève du quotidien et à l'échelle d'un
CAD et puis pour terminer cette revue de
presse des territoires Mathias et bien
on va aller dans le département de la
Charente ouais je ne sais pas ce que
vous faites ce weekend Alexandre mais si
vous aimez la BD c'est à angoulem que ça
se passe coup d'envoie du 51e Festival
International de la Bande desessiné
alors il y aura des expos des rencontres
des dédicaces une édition qui couronne
la Britannique Posy Simons avec son
Grand Prix vous avez une BD préférée
Alexandre h Z on va dire Tintin ouais
Tintin c'est pas mal Frédéri
une BD préféré j'aime toutes les bandes
dessinées euh Astérix et obéx allez
pareil
Astérix 13 il pas long merci beaucoup
Mathias pour cette revue de la presse
régionale merci Paul Cassia merci
Frédéric Dav d'avoir participé à ce club
et de nous avoir expliqué les enjeux de
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
sur cette loi immigration c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous d'information sur
Public Sénat votre émissionans public
présenté par Thomas HUG et puis demain à
8h Orian manch revient et recevra
François Xavier bam eurodéputé tête de l
les républicain aux élections
européennes très bonne journée sur
Public
Sénat